[Applause]
foreign
of defiance against China's leadership
police drag away protesters in the
country's biggest city Shanghai they're
calling for president Xi Jinping to step
down and lockdowns to be lifted
so after 10 people were killed in a fire
at an apartment Block in urumchi social
media users blamed a lockdown in the
xinjiang region for hampering rescue
efforts
analysts say growing opposition to
China's zero code policy is fueling
wider unrest because of how many people
are on the streets on the one hand but
also because it goes from the topic uh
covet lockdown to
um questioning the whole system of China
the government of the Communist party
and of Xi Jinping because the people see
him responsible for this zero call with
policy so they are the leadership must
be worried very much and it's very hard
for them what to do
vigils have been held at universities
across China
and here at shanghai's William Key Road
as curved cases surge China is the last
major world power to enforce a zero
covid-19 strategy it's continuing with
SNAP lockdowns lengthy quarantines and
mass testing to deal with outbreaks
methods abandoned by other major Nations
record numbers of covid-19 infections
have been recorded for days in a row and
many people are running out of patience
Barbara and gopa Al Jazeera